[Applause]
susan
progress is possible we're moving
good afternoon everyone i said from the
beginning of my uh campaign madam
speaker that uh
the campaign for president throughout
you would call me and tell me keep it up
it was about bringing people together by
uniting the country
we need to reunite we need to unite
as one people one nation one america
and that was the thing i was most often
criticized about saying how can you
unite the country
we must unite the country i said it my
kickoff speech in philadelphia
i said it again when i spoke at
gettysburg
and i emphasized it in my inaugural
address
a lot of people pressed to elected
officials were
somewhat skeptical of that could be done
it's just beginning but i'm confident we
can do this and so much more
and i believe with every fiber in my
being
that there are simple core values and
beliefs
that should bring us together america as
americans
one of them is standing together against
hate
against racism the ugly poison that has
long haunted and plagued our nation
today i can say that because of all of
you many of you sitting right in front
of me
you've taken that first step this
important step
i'd like to thank the congress and the
members who are here today democrats and
republicans
who came together to get the covet 19
hate crimes act
on my desk well on a desk i'm about to
sign
but i want to thank the majority leader
schumer
i want to thank speaker pelosi for your
leadership
i also want to thank our the leader from
the state of kentucky for letting it go
forward
it's important it's important most of
all
amazing senator
i called you maisy i apologize man
i called chuck chuck anyway yeah
senator hirano senator tammy duckworth
who
helped deliver this 94 to one vote
when you get involved tammy you don't
screw around you just
94-1 state representative grace mann and
judy chu who helped deliver a 600
and excuse me 364 to 62 vote in the
house of representatives
that's incredible i also want to thank
as i said
republican members in congress for their
leadership including senator moran
and senator collins i also want to thank
the as i said to tell and to all
to all of the folks all the people here
today
who are involved and those of you
whether you're in the congress or not
supporting this effort i say thank you
thank you thank you we have a lot more
to do
we simply haven't seen this kind of
bipartisanship for much
too long in washington you're showing
our that our democracy can work and
deliver for the american people
just days after the mass shooting in
atlanta
uh area the vice president harrison i we
went down to atlanta to meet with asian
americans
and the community across georgia it was
a raw
and emotional visit we had we heard
about their pain their fear
anger and all that existed in the
community and the feelings were about
those feelings that
they felt invisible not seen
we heard how too many asian americans
have been waking up each morning this
past year
genuinely genuinely fearing for their
safety
just opening the door and walking down
the street
and safety for the loved ones the moms
and dads
when they let their kids out the door to
go to school
or attacked blamed
scapegoated harassed during this
pandemic
living in fear for their lives as i said
just walking
down the street grandparents afraid to
leave their homes even to get vaccinated
for fear being attacked small business
owners targeted and gunned down
students worried about two things covet
and being bullied documented incidents
of hate against asian americans has seen
a shocking spike as the vice president
has outlined at the front of which her
comments
let alone let alone the ones that have
never been reported
gut-wrenching attacks on some of the
most vulnerable people in our nation the
elderly low-wage workers women
brutally attacked simply by walking
outside or waiting for a bus
asian-american women suffered twice as
many incidents harassment
and violence as asian american men
the conversation we had in atlanta is
one we're hearing all across the country
that all of this hate hides in plain
sight
it hides in plain sight and too often
it is met with silence silenced by the
media
silenced by our politics and silenced by
our history
for centuries asian americans native
hawaiians pacific islanders diverse and
vibrant communities
have helped build this nation only to be
often stepped over
forgotten or ignored
you know lived here for generations
was still considered by some the other
the other it's wrong
it's simply to use the phrase it's
simply un-american
my message to all of those who are
hurting is we see
the congress said we see you
and we are committed to stop the hatred
and the bias
my first week in office i signed a
presidential memorandum
directing federal agencies all of them
to combat the resurgence of xenophobia
not just one
every agency attorney general garland
deputy attorney general lisa monaco
associate attorney general gupta
are all here today the department of
justice
is strengthening his partnership with
the community to prevent these crimes
in addition to its other work to take on
violent extremism
and domestic terrorism and with the new
law
this new law the department of justice
and our entire administration is going
to step
up right now this is a critical problem
of hate crimes being
underreported it stems from two
challenges
first there's lack of resources and
training for state and local law
enforcement to accurately identify and
report
hate crimes to the fbi secondly
for more people in communities of color
there are language and cultural barriers
and how to communicate what's happening
to them
this law is going to make a difference
for example the department of justice
will issue clear guidance for state city
and tribal and law enforcement agencies
on how to establish online reporting of
hate crimes
and work with the department of health
and human services to raise public
awareness of covet 19 hate crimes that
occurred
during the pandemic i'll also be a
devoted official
at the department of justice whose sole
job
is to expedite the review of hate crime
reports
and thanks to two families here today
we'll all help state
and local governments ensure hate crime
information is more accessible to the
public
the family of heather heyer a civil
rights activist whose life was taken
standing up to nazis marching from the
shadows of
vengeance in charlottesville the family
of collide jabbaro
a proud son of a family who's immigrated
from lebanon
in search of new beginnings with gunned
down in front of their home
here in america united states america
by a neighbor fueled by hate
colleed and heather were murdered on the
same day
one year apart instead of sharing the
dreams they had for their children
both families share profound grief
and they've shown incredible courage to
turn their pain into purpose
i hope you'll not be offended but ask
both families to please stand
i want to thank you
i want to thank you for being here
i know it's hard no matter how
celebratory it is it's
a lost being changed
when you have to show up at something
memorialize it your family
it's like you got the news 10 seconds
ago
it's the hardest thing to do
i know from experience it takes enormous
courage
but i hope i hope that every day has
passed
the memory showing daughter
brings a smile to your lips before it
brings a tear to your eye
because i promise you a lot of people
understand who've gone through similar
things
it's hard so i really mean when i say
thank you
thank you for being here it takes a lot
of courage
because of you the amendment named in
honor of khalid and heather
is now law to make sure that hate crimes
are more accurately counted and reported
and hopefully leading to a continued
focus on
ending these crimes it will provide
resources to create specialized hate
crimes units
that will also help states create
hotlines for hate crimes at state and
local levels
that will be accessible for people with
limited english proficiency
and it provides resources for training
for state and local law enforcement
to identify investigate and report these
heinous crimes
but of all the good the law can do
we have to change our hearts
we have to change the hearts of the
american people
hate ken i mean this from the bottom of
my heart
hate can be given no safe harbor in
america
i mean it no safe harbor
can't be dismissed like well that's just
what happens
my sister valerie and i talk about it
all the time
you've got to speak up speak up and
speak out
it's on all of us all of us together
to make it stop my message is
to all those who think this doesn't
matter to them or this is not a problem
look around look in the mirror
look in the eyes of your children
every one of us are lessened
every one of us are lessened and we're
all hurt
by this hate and as a way of seeping
sort of through the cracks in the
communities and children who
in fact wouldn't have crossed their mind
words have consequences as the senator
knows
he preaches it he understands it
consequences but silence
is complicit silence is complicity
and we cannot be complicit we have to
speak
out we have to act that's what you've
done
and i can't thank you enough
i'm proud today i'm proud today
of the united states i'm proud today
of our political system the united
states congress i'm proud today
that democrats and republicans have
stood up together
to say something
let me close with this
grief as we all know is universal
but so is hope so is love
sounds corny but it really is it really
is
and hope and love can be contagious
we're the united states of
we're america and decent people
we're unique among all nations and that
we are uniquely a product
of a document not an ethnicity
not a religion not a geography
of a document and think about this i'm
being literal
uniquely a product with document and
says we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men and women are created equal
endowed by their creator with certain
inalienable rights
including life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
every time we're silent
every time we let hate flourish
we make a lie of who we are as a nation
i mean it literally
we cannot let the very foundation
of this country continue to be eaten
away
like it has been in other moments in our
history and happening again
i looked at this law that you all passed
as maybe the first
break the first significant break
on a moment in our history that has to
be turned around
not democrat has to be turned around
as a consequence we should do what is
required
by the obligations of this democracy
by our faith in god and our faith in
each other
to do justice to love mercy
to walk humbly and as fellow human
beings
and fellow americans remember
we're unique in all history as a nation
this is the united states of america for
god's sake
and god bless you all particularly those
who push this through
and continue to push it now i'm going to
sign this bill
which is a great honor
i don't know who's calling but tell them
we're busy
i was going to say unless it's my sister
but she's here
so i'd like to invite to the stage
senator hirano senator duckworth
congresswoman grace mang congresswoman
judy chu
congresswoman don beyer senator richard
blumenthal
and senator moran but i don't think he
could be here today
actually he should have you i should put
the table down the middle of all of you
and sign it down there but thank you
thank you
all right
[Laughter]
okay
thank you
[Applause]